welcome back to new rock stars I'm Eric
Boss and Deadpool 3 will be Marvel
Studios one big movie of 2024 which
might be why every rumor in theory that
everybody is coming back to watch
Deadpool Kill the fox X-Men Universe are
so easy to believe we've seen set photos
of him and Wolverine tangoing on the
crumbling ruins of the 20th Century Fox
logo I mean that alone tells us that
anything is possible but between the
other X-Men we've seen before and the
TVA to x23 and Taylor Swift which of
these are nice valid theories and which
of them are naughty let's play nice
versus naughty with 23 characters
confirmed or anticipated to be in
Deadpool 3 and really whether they're
stocking stuffers or lumps of Cole one
Ryan reyolds Deadpool obviously he's in
the movie he in the title of the movie
but presumably we're going to pick up
with him as he bounces through the
timelines using Cable's time travel
wristwatch from Deadpool 2 sounds like
cable will not be in this movie though
two Hugh Jackman Wolverine also clearly
in the movie Last Summer Set photo shows
Hugh in the classic blue and yellow
outfit so we are looking at an X-Men
universe that's not exactly the one from
the original films but a new one one
using elements from places like the
animated Xmen series three Marina backer
and Vanessa we forget about her but she
is coming back in this movie Wade saved
her using the time travel device in
Deadpool 2 she's coming back for the
third film Brianna hildbrand negasonic
teenage Warhead she is returning as well
Colossus Voice by Define kichic is also
returning dopender played by Karen Sony
is returning he's had quite a year
voicing Pita pakar and Spider-Man across
spiderverse blind Al Leslie ugam also
returning yukoh sholi katsuna Nega Sonic
teenage Warheads girl girl also
returning and Peter Rob Delaney Survivor
from the X Force team that Deadpool
saved in the post credit Montage it's
also coming back go home sugar bear go
home though from Deadpool 2 it sounds
like we're not going to see ZZ beats
Domino or TJ Miller as weasel or
Juggernaut voiced by Ryan Reynolds
himself though we'll see as I said
anything's possible all right Emma Corin
known for playing Diana Spencer in past
seasons of the crown is playing a lead
villain role in this movie currently
unknown but scooper can we get some
toast claims that Corin is playing
Cassandra Nova Cassandra Nova is Charles
Xavier's evil twin whom he tried to
telepathically kill in the womb but she
spend her life rebuilding a body to get
her revenge all right Matt mcfan Tom
WAMS Gans from succession is also
playing an undisclosed role there were
some rumors that he'd be playing a TVA
agent named Paradox assigned to
Deadpool's case but this is one of my
favorite stories from the past couple
months in October a fascinating Reddit
post claims to have completely made that
rumor up and everyone just went with it
including scoopers like can we get some
toast but can we get some toast
denied it and said that they sorts that
independently who knows okay next
Jennifer Garner Alexa was also confirmed
last summer by The Hollywood Reporter
but recently collider Steven we asked
Jenifer Garner about this and she
responded by playing koi did you ever
think you were going to wear the Electra
suit again I don't know what you're
talking
about so what could you mean I'm
hypothetically thinking you could be in
a dead coal sequel hypothetically not
that I'm aware of okay I'll avoid I'll
move on so it's Jennifer Garner is
goinging back as elra and it sounds like
she is I don't think we would see her
without Ben app like Daredevil last
summer scooper Casey Walsh claimed that
benle was spotted on the set for
Deadpool 3 and this would have been
around the time when they were rushing
to shoot remaining footage before all
the actors went on strike in July while
sha Levy and Ryan Reynolds have claimed
they don't want to change Wolverine's
death in 2017's Logan the latest rumor
is that dapne Keane x23 from the 2017
Logan film is in talks to prizer role
this comes from scooper Daniel Rickman
AKA Daniel rpk thinking is that maybe
Deadpool accidentally wanders through a
portal into that film Wolverine's grave
site on the Canadian border then x23 who
is keeping watch over that grave just
pounces on Deadpool and Claws him nearly
to death until he leaves so that's what
they meant by they weren't going to
touch the grave like Deadpool can't even
get close thank you to geology for
partnering with us to bring you this
video and also for giving our audiences
exclusive access to their new try before
you bu program you've probably heard me
mention geology before the 28 time award
winning skin hair and body care comp
company recogniz in men's health hype
Feast bird Esquire askmen and Oprah
daily grooming Awards but hey I get it
it can be tough to change a skincare
routine or start a new one part of
what's nice about giy is they create
simple and effective skincare and Hair
Care routines customized just for you
and now if you want to try that new
routine out before you buy a bunch of
stuff you can geology is offering new
Rockstar viewers a free trial of their
eight-piece skincare set with their try
before you buy a program you can
experience a new skincare routine
risk-free for 14 days if you don't love
it send it back it's that easy the set
is valued at $139 all you pay today is
the price of shipping and if you order
today get a free vitamin C plus e fuic
acid as a gift you don't need to return
it that's yours just head to geology.com
neww rockstars and get your free trial
and geology will send you a personalized
skincare routine and if you don't mind
me I'm going to take some geology and uh
uh look good for the rest of this video
and then next up oh I don't know how we
buried this one so late in the video my
apologies to all swifties but Taylor
Swift dazzler when Taylor Swift was
spotted at the Chief's game with sha
leevy and Ryan Reynolds it led to a week
of insanity over how she might appear in
deadp 3 with most common thinking being
that she's going to play the muted
singer dazzler we actually sent CM out
on Hollywood Boulevard to ask real fans
what they thought Sean Levy finally
broke his silence on this saying quote
I'm going to cross the board no comment
because that's a double whammy that's
Taylor related and it's MCU related I'm
no dummy you're going to have to wait
and see and when asked about Taylor
Swift by the Vancouver son Ryan Reynold
said quote I think it is a sign of how
eager people are to get a peek behind
the curtain in this world every single
one of secrets and spoilers will be
revealed on July 26th which is Deadpool
3's release date so I don't know I I
feel like if Taylor Swift was not
involved they wouldn't dare even tease
that she might be in it okay returning
to some other familiar mutants that we
are now expecting Kelsey gramar Beast
Hank McCoy after his surprised
appearance in the post credit scene for
the Marvels really he is now the second
member of the X-Men that we've seen on
screen in the MCU and I would be
surprised if they created that character
design for just one Cameo and in that
Marvel scene He also mentioned professor
Charles Xavier who in the MCU if Beast
is played by K grammar would be played
by Patrick Stewart obviously not the
dead Charles Xavier from Doctor Strange
of the multivers of Madness but whatever
Charles is in this new X-Men Universe
because back in February 9th of this
year Patrick Stewart told comicbook.com
I've been told to stand by I know
nothing more than that honest and if
they get Patrick Stewart I think we also
got to consider his best friend Ian
melen Magneto someone whose name has
also been floated around just by some
you know not 100% reliable sources
similar claims are actually made that
shanning Tatum Gambit filmed to Cameo
for Deadpool 3 this would be after Tatum
reportedly had a Gambit film in the
works that never made it out of
development hell next halberry storm
turn some heads back last may you
remember when she posted an Instagram
photo of herself with new short white
hair which could be part of Aurora
Monroe's new look for Deadpool 3 May
24th would have been just a couple weeks
into Deadpool 3's production and storm
being in this would line up with rumors
that James Mars and cyclops and found
key Jansen Jean Gray are also returning
for cameos and the last on this list dog
poow this is actually confirmed Ryan
Reynolds confirmed it on Twitter and a
couple more in case you think the first
few don't count spoiler warning on these
Sabertooth was spotted on set according
to the Daily Mirror returning from the
2000 X-Men movie when he was played by
Tyler M fighting Deadpool and Wolverine
and getting beheaded apparently toad was
also spotted who was originally played
by Darth Maul actor Ray Park in the 2000
film so which of these rumors are nice
which are naughty and how much can we
trust them well Deadpool and Wolverine
the returning Deadpool two cast Electra
and I'm going to say Daredevil as well
as x23 and yes dogpool I think they're
nice meanwhile uh Taylor Swift and the
rest of the X-Men cast and the exact
roles that Karen and mcfan are playing
according to these scoopers I think is
just a bit too naughty it's not false
yet just naughty here's what I'll say
though if Marvel Studios plans on one
film in all of 2024 I think that gives
greater weight to the exact way this
X-Men Universe was introduced in the
post credit scene of the Marvels I know
I know Marvel Studios just ends all
their movies with post credit scenes
many of which we never really follow up
on but I think people are sleeping on
this post-edit scene just because the
Marvel's really underperformed in the
box office I think it's extremely
important so don't sleep on binary or
Hank McCoy beast and I think it was
really important that Beast mentioned
Charles Xavier he says that Charles
specifically asked for an update on
whatever's going on with this female
Cosmic multi-dimensional traveler could
this particular Charles be particularly
worried about a Cassandra Nova trying to
kill him you can support us by grabbing
something from nerd rot. shop everyone
have a happy holiday and I'll see you
soon
bye
[Music]